bienvenue à ce point presse du début de
semaine
je voulais juste commence évidemment en
vous redémarrez les moments importants
de notre semaine pour notre famille
politique
outre ce point presse de a prédit
laurent wauquiez notre président ce
rembrandt
public dans l'yonne à 19 heures jeudi ce
sera une journée
gm puisque laurent wauquiez serait au
sommet du parti populaire européen à
maastricht à 19 heures eric woerth
notre côté général sera en réunion
publique à bruxelles
et puis au samedi prochain 22 octobre
grand déjeuner militants en présence de
laurent wauquiez dans le vaucluse
voilà pour les moments importants de la
semaine concernant les républicains je
voulais commencer ce ce point presse
évidemment par ce qui fait et fonde
l'actualité de ce week end et de ce
début de semaine
concernant françois hollande françois
hollande
est au coeur de plusieurs polémiques on
l'a vu ces dernières semaines je
pourrais même dire ces derniers mois et
je pourrais même ajouté ces dernières
années mais c'est vrai que force est de
constater que le livre qui lui est
consacré a profondément une manière
assez juste ébranlé et écoeuré nos
compatriotes
alors il tente tant bien que mal de s'en
expliquer chez les certains de vos
confrères depuis depuis ce matin mais on
voit bien que françois hollande a
totalement abîmé et désincarnée la
fonction présidentielle qu'il s'est
présenté aux yeux de nos compatriotes
comme un président bavard
un président qui préfère parler aux
journalistes
mais mentir aux français sur toutes les
grandes thématiques et qui a démontré
son impuissance public et son
incompétence sur les grands sujets de
préoccupations de nos concitoyens sur la
question plus précise encore de
l'économie en général et de la politique
industrielle française en particulier
françois hollande est aux yeux de nos
concitoyens aujourd'hui une véritable
catastrophe industrielle cent mille
emplois perdus dans le secteur de
l'industrie depuis d'année 2012 et
chaque mois qui passe apporte
hélas son lot d'échecs de mensonges sur
ces questions là
chacun se souvient de petroplus goodyear
à amiens de psa aulnay de psa d'ailleurs
de manière plus large avec les 2000
emplois menacés comme on vient de
l'apprendre
et tout cela s'incarne de manière
absolument caricaturale du fossé de
l'océan entre ses paroles ses propos ses
promesses d'un côté et ses actes et
réalisations et réussite de l'autre
c'est florange il avait promis aux
ouvriers de florange une réponse à
travers un repreneur repreneur qui n'est
jamais arrivé
quand on voit dans les avants papier ou
dans l'ambiance générale dans le
contexte actuel l'état d'esprit des
salariés des ouvriers de cette région et
des salariés plus particulièrement de
florange
on voit l'exaspération l'inquiétude et
la colère qui domine
on pourrait même y ajouter au delà de
l'exemple de florange l'incroyable échec
sur la question d'alstom la gauche
socialiste est incapable d'inventer une
nouvelle politique industrielle sa
politique industrielle ne relèvent que
des vieilles recettes de la dépense
publique et donc françois hollande sur
la question industrielle sur la question
économique est plus que jamais le
président de l'impuissance publique et
d'ailleurs les ouvriers qui sont
interrogés utilisent ces mots et ces
termes
al'inverse de ce que nous avions eu le
courage nous de faire entre 2007 et 2012
autour de nicolas sarkozy avec une vraie
politique au service des ouvriers chacun
se souvient des heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées qui avait bénéficié à 9
millions de nos compatriotes augmentant
de manière significative
malgré une crise bancaire et économique
et financière mondiale augmentant de
manière significative le pouvoir d'achat
de la même manière la majorité
précédente entre 2007 et 2012 avaient
mis en place vous en souvenez la tva
anti délocalisation qui offrait enfin
des perspectives d'amélioration de la
compétitivité de nos entreprises et de
nos industries et donc françois hollande
véritable catastrophe industrielle
aujourd'hui et malgré ces bavardages et
ces cérémonies plus ou moins officielles
incapable d'apporter une réponse
concrète solide forte à la tante de nos
concitoyens ça c'était sur la question
de florange deuxième grand sujet hélas
semaine après semaine nous découvrons
effaré combien ce gouvernement est aussi
le gouvernement de l'insécurité et de
l'échec en matière de sécurité publique
et de justice
regardons ce qui s'est passé encore ces
dernières heures à mantes la jolie
c'est le cas aussi sur l'ensemble des
territoires perdus de la république il
est indispensable comme le dit
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup d'audace et de
courage ce matin le patron du syndicat
alliance syndicats de policiers d'île de
france
il est indispensable désormais d'entamer
une politique de reconquête des zones de
non-droit et des territoires perdus de
la république il y à un chiffre qui
marque tous nos compatriotes 3267
fonctionnaires de police blessés dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions depuis le
1er janvier 2016 une hausse de 30%
et quelle est la réponse apportée par le
gouvernement c'est de toujours traiter
des conséquences plutôt que de
s'attaquer aux causes alors les
conséquences
pourquoi ne pas imaginer des véhicules
blindés des tenues de protection plus
aboutie pour nos policiers
la question n'est pas là la question
c'est de s'attaquer aux causes et des
dissuader 7 et ceux qui refusent le
respect de l'état de droit dans une
république comme la france dans une
société comme la france le laxisme n'a
pas sa place et l'autorité de l'état
doit s'imposer partout et pour tous nous
avons nous des propositions concrètes
qui avaient été mises en oeuvre
d'ailleurs lors du dernier quinquennat
et qui ont été totalement oubliés
abandonnés rejeté par la majorité
socialiste
j'en veux pour preuve la politique
pénale laxiste par exemple de madame
taubira j'en veux pour preuve le refus
de construire des dizaines de milliers
vingt à trente mille nouvelles places de
prison sur le territoire national projet
voté par la présente la précédente
majorité abandonnée par le gouvernement
socialiste est désormais devant
l'ampleur de la situation
on entend ici ou là le premier ministre
ou le garde des sceaux reparler à
nouveau de la nécessité de construire
des places de prison cinq années de
perdu là encore ce sera la même question
sur le nécessaire assouplissement de la
légitime défense
nos policiers et nos gendarmes ont le
droit d'être protégé il est
indispensable qu'on ait le courage et
l'audace de revoir cette politique c'est
la même question moi je suis maire d'une
commune rurale et je pense à mes trente
six mille collègues sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
il nous faut renforcer les pouvoirs de
police du maire et il nous faut partir
d'un principe tout simple
oui les polices municipales ont le droit
d'être armé ça doit être un principe
nationale appliquée partout et pour tous
il nous faudra d'ailleurs améliorer et
agrandir les prérogatives des polices
municipales que ce soit sur les fouilles
de véhicules ou les contrôles d'identité
il en va de la de la sécurité de notre
pays et vous savez que nous proposons
plus largement la création d'un grand
ministère de la sécurité intérieure qui
pourra améliorer le fonctionnement de
l'ensemble de nos services sur ces
questions là en tout cas nous rappelons
ce matin à nouveau au nom de toute la
famille des républicains que nous sommes
du côté des forces de l'ordre nous
sommes du côté des policiers
nous sommes du côté des gendarmes nous
sommes du côté de l'ordre face à
l'anarchie
face au laxisme parce que l'ordre
l'ordre c'est la colonne vertébrale
d'une société qui avance et qui vit
sereinement sans ordre et sans sécurité
il n'y a plus de liberté
le désordre pénalisé s'attaque avant
tout aux petits aux gens modestes à ceux
qui n'ont pas les moyens de se protéger
et donc la droite républicaine et du
côté des petits de celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas ces moyens là et qui demande à
l'état et à l'ordre des républicains de
s'affirmer partout et pour tous sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
c'est un enjeu de société et de
civilisation et la gauche là encore a
failli de manière monumentale troisième
grande thématique qui évidemment a
occupé le devant de la scène ce week end
c'est la question de la gpa à travers la
manifestation qui a réuni plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de
nos concitoyens hier à paris nous
voulons dire là encore au nom des
républicains de manière très claire
qu'il s'agit à travers la gpa d'une
question de société de civilisation ces
deux sociétés deux visions de la société
qui s'affrontent et qui dont la réponse
dépendra de notre capacité à assumer
affirmer nos valeurs et ce que nous
voulons une société soumise aux forces
de l'argent aux forces de la finance à
l'obsession du profit à
l'ultralibéralisme qui nivelle tout qui
marchandent tous et qui fait croire que
tout se vaut et tout se vend
non mille fois non chez nous aux
républicains nous considérons que la
dignité de l'être humain l'emportent sur
tout le reste et qu'il n'est pas
question de céder à la pression de
quelques-uns et d'un petit lobby qui
verraient d'un bon oeil cette idée
absurde cupides et à vide que nous
pourrions aller jusqu'à louer le ventre
des femmes à louer et marchander le
corps des pauvres il est indispensable
encore au nom de nos principes de
civilisation et d'une société équilibrée
que nous rappelions ses principes
fondamentaux et la société une société
qui grandit qui s'épanouit qui rassemble
le plus grand nombre
c'est une société qui rappelle que
l'intégrité du corps humain que la
dignité de l'être humain sont des
valeurs qui ne se négocie pas tout ne
peut pas se résumer à une
marchandisation du monde à une
marchandisation des corps à une
marchandisation des comportements nous
rappelons nous que nous ne sommes pas
des consommateurs nous ne voulons pas
d'une société de consommateurs nous
sommes des citoyens
nous ne sommes pas les clients du
supermarché du monde
nous sommes des citoyens amoureux de
notre terre et de ne sommes pas des
libres penseurs nous sommes des penseurs
libres voilà c'est ça l'état d'esprit de
la famille des républicains
tout ne se vaut pas
ne se marchande pas et le règne de
l'argent de la finance du profit de la
spéculation de la marchandisation
ce règne là ne peut pas l'emporter et
c'est le rôle des partis politiques
ces rôles de la droite française de
rappeler avec force enthousiasme
sérénité et détermination
ces valeurs profondément ancré dans la
société française voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire sur ces trois grands
sujets la question éthique d'une vision
de la société à travers la gpa la
question de la sécurité de l'autorité de
l'état à travers les événements à
nouveau insupportable de mantes la jolie
et puis cette question ô combien crucial
pour tous nos concitoyens dans une
france qui se désindustrialise de plus
en plus la nécessité que la france
retrouve le rôle d'un état stratège d'un
état qui défendent une industrie forte
parent parce qu'un pays sans industrie
un pays qui ne se verraient qu'à l'aune
d'une politique du tertiaire ou des
services est un pays mort
il nous faut une agriculture il nous
faut une industrie agroalimentaire il
nous faut des ouvriers nous faut des
usines
c'est l'honneur et c'est la force d'une
france à nouveau forte que d'offrir une
compétitivité une protection et un
soutien très appuyé au niveau national
comme européen à une véritable politique
industrielle française